[Music]
my son and I watched the Captain America
movies together he's 10 and I was
telling you he loves those movies I love
those movies and we watch them together
that's like one of our things that we do
and he loves your character and your you
have said that you think crossbones in
Captain America is one of the best kind
of bad guys I think we have a picture of
crossbones there yes there he is
and you think crossbones he's a badass
you think he could take and you've said
you said he could take the Hulk
I think Hulk is a dum-dum Oh Hulk I
can't rip the Hulk like I did one of my
guys can stand behind the Hulk and I
could push the whole yeah I think you
could trick him with like a bad
investment
[Applause]
okay you know what I mean Tony Stark not
so much but yeah Tony Stark yes he's
quick he's smart yeah that's the hide in
that I'm the baddest I love that I love
that attitude that yummy marble doesn't
think so they killed me off kind of quit
yeah they could always bring you back oh
I can bring you back they could can
always bring you back I what I love is
and there's a great fight scene that you
and Chris Evans have that's I think
people just go people that have seen the
movie go back and look at this this
scene all the time where you're in an
elevator yeah oh you own a bunch of
other bad guys days six days all right
an elevator it's an elevator fight scene
with with you guys in Chris Evans as
Captain America and it's a fantastic
scene really fun to do was it hard to
shoot it was because there were six very
large man in the elevator we did it for
six days but you know we early on Chris
realized that out really gonna hit you
so he said no Grillo you've got I'm
getting black and blue I said yeah keep
your hand just keep your hands up
by the end of the fight we both we would
pack the nice we had to get massages I
mean it was it was bad so when you're
you're supposed to pretend to hit people
you just really hit them
doesn't it look better it looks
fantastic
yeah it looks better okay all right all
right so you're off my to-do list of
pretend to have a fight
you